road to zero
sharing the road together
our urban and rural communities live
side by side in the waimakariri district
no matter where you live you have a part
to play in keeping each other safe on
our roads hi i'm kathy and this is my
pride and joy zephyr and we live down in
airwell
we love riding out we love hacking out
and i'd love to be able to hack out
across farmland but unfortunately
nowadays we really can't so a lot of our
riding involves road riding
the thing is that they don't
automatically be really good they have
to learn to be good on the road and that
means putting mileage on the road with
them
hi my name is liam and this is molly and
we live in waikuku
when i hold the dogs it's hard to judge
the speed of the traffic because most of
the cars are speeding the speed limit
through here is 50 kilometers an hour
and i've seen people going like up to
100 kilometers an hour
we can all make a difference to how
other people feel by the way we behave
on the roads
i'd like to see drivers slowing down for
kids and dogs because it makes everyone
on the road or on the side safer
the thing is that we're all sharing the
road and if you can slow down and just
just take it quietly past us we would
really really appreciate that
[Music]
it's our safety it's our community
and slow down
it helps out everyone look after each
other
so ask yourself
am i driving to the conditions who else
is around me on the road can i slow down
a bit and give others a bit more space
am i prepared if someone else makes a
mistake
so no matter how you're using the road
everyone has a part to play
we can all make a difference